I hope with my books I'm saying
uh this isn't a how-to guide but this is
somebody you can walk alongside you can
see
Einstein growing up Jewish in Germany
you can see Jennifer doudner growing up
or as an outsider or a Leonardo da Vinci
or Elon Musk you know in really violent
South Africa with a psychologically
difficult father and getting off the
train when he goes to anti-apartheid
concert with his brother and there's a a
man with a knife sticking out of his
head and they step into the pool of
blood and it's sticky on their souls
this causes you know scars that last the
rest of your life
and the question is not how do you avoid
getting scarred it's you know how do you
deal with it
the following is a conversation with
Walter Isaacson one of the greatest
biography writers ever having written
incredible books on Albert Einstein
Steve Jobs Leonardo da Vinci Jennifer
doudna Benjamin Franklin Henry Kissinger
and now a new one on Elon Musk
we talked for hours on and off the mic
I'm sure we'll talk many more times
Walter is a truly special writer thinker
Observer and human being I highly
recommend people read his new book on
Elon I'm sure there will be short-term
controversy but in the long term I think
it will inspire millions of young people
especially with difficult childhoods
with hardship in their surroundings or
in their own minds to take on the
hardest problems in the world and to
build solutions to those problems no
matter how impossible the odds
in this conversation Walter and I cover
all of his books and use personal
stories from them to speak to the bigger
principles of striving for greatness in
science in Tech engineering art politics
and life
there are many things in the new Elon
book that I felt are best saved for when
I speak to Elon directly again on this
podcast which will be soon enough
perhaps it's also good to mention here
that my friendships like with Elon nor
any other influence like money access
Fame power will ever result in me
sacrificing my Integrity ever
I do like to celebrate the good in
people to empathize and to understand
but I also like to call people out on
their with respect and with
compassion
if I fail I fail due to a lack of skill
not a lack of Integrity I work hard to
improve
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Walter Isaacson
what is the role of a difficult
childhood in the lives of great men and
women great minds is that a requirement
is it a catalyst or is it just a simple
Coincidence of Fate well it's not a
requirement some people with happy
childhood to do quite well but it
certainly is true that a lot of really
driven people are driven because they're
harnessing the Demons of their childhood
even Barack Obama's uh sentence and his
Memoirs which is I think every
successful man is either trying to live
up to the expectations of of his father
or live down the sins of his father and
for Elon it's especially true because he
had both a violent and difficult
childhood and a very psychologically
problematic father
he's got those demons uh dancing around
in his head and by harnessing them it's
part of the reason that he does riskier
more adventurous Wilder things and maybe
I would ever do you've written that Elon
talked about his father and that at
times it felt like mental torture the
the interaction with him during his
childhood can you describe some of the
things you've learned yeah well Elon and
Kimball would tell me that for example
when Elon got bullied on the playground
and one day was pushed down some
concrete steps and had his face pummeled
so badly that Kimball said I couldn't
really recognize him when he was in the
hospital for almost a week but when he
came home Elon had to stand in front of
his father and his father berated him
for more than an hour and said he was
stupid and took the side of the of the
person who had beaten him that's
probably one of the more traumatic
events of elon's Life yes and there's
also veld school which is a sort of
paramilitary camp that young South
African boys got sent to and at one
point you know he was scrawny he has
very bad at picking up social cues and
emotional cues he talks about being
Asperger's and so he gets uh traumatized
at a camp like that but the second time
time he went he'd gotten bigger he had
shot up to almost six feet and he
learned a little bit of Judo and he
realized that if he was getting beaten
up he might it might hurt him but he
would just punch the person in the nose
as hard as possible so that sense of
always punching back has also been
ingrained in Elon I spent a lot of time
talking Arrow musk his father Elon done
talked to Meryl musk anymore his father
nor does Kimball it's been years and uh
Errol doesn't even have elon's email so
a lot of times Arrow will be sending me
emails and arrow had one of those Jekyll
and Hyde personalities he was you know a
great mind of engineering and especially
Material Science I knew how to build a
Wilderness Camp in South Africa using
Micah and how it would not conduct the
heat but he also would go into these
dark periods in which he would just be
psychologically abusive and of course
May musk says to me the his mother who
divorced Daryl early on said the danger
for Elon is that he becomes his father
and every now and then you've been with
him so much LAX and you know him well
he'll even talk to you about the demons
about Diablo dancing in his head I mean
he he gets it he's self-aware but you've
probably seen him at times where those
demons take over and he goes really dark
and really quiet and uh Grimes
says you know I can tell a minute or two
in advance when demon Mode's about to
happen and he'll go a bit dark I was you
know here at Austin wanted dinner with a
group and you could tell suddenly
something had triggered him and he was
going to go dark I've watched it in
meetings where somebody will say we
can't make that part for less than 200
or no that's wrong and he'll berate them
and then he steps out of it as you know
that too the the huge snap out where
suddenly he's showing you Monty pythons
get on his phone he's joking about
things so I think coming out of the
childhood there were just mini facets
maybe even many personalities the
engineering mode the silly mode the
charismatic mode the Visionary mode but
also the demon in dark mode I'll quote
you cited about elon's really stood out
to me I forget uh who was from but
inside the man he's still there as a
child the child's standing in front of
his dad that was Tallulah his second
wife
and she's great uh she's an English
actress they've been married twice
actually and Tallulah said that's just
him from his childhood he's a drama
addict Kimball says that as well
and
I asked why and he said and Tallulah
said
you know for him love and family are
kind of associated with those
psychological torments and in many ways
he'll Channel I mean Tallulah would be
with him in
2008 when the company was going back or
whatever it may have been or later
and he would be so stressed he would
vomit and then he would Channel things
that his father had said use phrases his
father had said to him
and so she told me deep inside the man
is this man-child still standing in
front of his father
to a degree is that true for many of us
do you think
I think it's true but in many different
ways I'll say something personal which
is I was blessed and perhaps it's a bit
of a downside too but the fact I had the
greatest father he could ever imagine
and mother they were the kindest people
you'd ever want to meet I grew up in a
magical place in New Orleans my dad was
an engineer an electrical engineer and
you know he was always kind
perhaps
I'm not quite as driven or as crazed I
don't have to prove things so I get to
write about Elon Musk I get to write
about you know Einstein or Steve Jobs or
Leonardo da Vinci who as you know was
totally torn by demons and had different
difficult childhood situations not even
legitimized by his father so sometimes
those of us who are lucky enough to have
really gentle sweet childhood
we grew up with fewer demons but we grow
up with fewer drives and we end up maybe
being Boswell and not being Dr Johnson
we end up being the Observer not being
the doer and so I always respect those
who are in the arena I don't you know
you don't see yourself as a man in the
arena I've had a gentle sweet career
and I've got to cover really interesting
people but I've never shot off a rocket
that might someday get to Mars I've
never moved us into the era of electric
vehicles I've never stayed up all night
on the factory floor
I don't have quite
those
either the drives or the
uh addiction to risk I mean elon's
addicted to risk he's addicted to
Adventure
me if I see something that's risky I
spend some time calculating okay upside
downside here uh but that's another
reason that people like Elon Musk get
stuff done
and people like me write about the Elon
musks one other aspect of this given a
difficult childhood whether it's Elon or
da Vinci
I wonder if there's some wisdom
some advice almost that you can draw
that you can give to people with
difficult childhoods I think all of us
have demons even those of us who grew up
in a magical part of New Orleans with
sweet parents yes and we all have demons
and
rule one in life is harness your demons
know that you're ambitious or not
ambitious or you're lazy or whatever
uh Leonardo da Vinci knew he was a
procrastinator you know I think
it's usual to know what's eating at you
know how to harness it
um
also know what you're good at I'll take
musk as another example
I'm a little bit more like Kimball musk
than Elon I maybe got over endowed with
the empathy Gene and what does that mean
well it means that I was okay when I ran
Time Magazine it was a group about a 150
people on the editorial floors and I
knew them all and we had a jolly time
when I went to CNN I was not very good
at being a manager or an executive of an
organization
uh I cared a little bit too much that
people didn't get annoyed at me or
um mad at me and Elon said that about
John McNeil for example who was
president of Tesla it's in the book I
talked to John McNeil a long time and he
says uh you know Elon just would fire
people be really rough on people he
didn't have the empathy for the people
in front of him and Elon says yeah
that's right and John McNeil couldn't
fire people he cared more about pleasing
the people in front of him than pleasing
the entire Enterprise or getting things
done being over endowed with a desire to
please people can make you less tough of
a manager and uh that doesn't mean there
aren't great people over in doubt Ben
Franklin over endowed with the desire to
please people the worst criticism of him
from John Adams and others was that he
was insinuating which kind of meant he
was always trying to
get people to like him uh but that
turned out to be a good thing when they
can't figure out the big state little
State issue at the Constitutional
Convention when they can't figure out
the Treaty of Paris whatever it is he
brings people together and that is his
superpower so to get back to the lessons
you asked and you know the first was
harness your demons
the second is to know your strengths and
your superpower
my superpower is definitely not being a
tough manager after running CNN for a
while I said okay I think I've proven I
don't really enjoy this or know how to
do this well
uh you know do I have other talents yeah
I think I have the talent to observe
people really closely
to write about it in a straight but I
hope interesting narrative style that's
a power it's totally different from
running an organization it took me until
three years of running CNN that I
realized I'm not cut to be an executive
in a really
High intense
situations Elon Musk is cut to be an
executive in highly intense situation so
much so that when things get less
intense when they actually are making
enough cars and
Rockets are going up and Landing
he thinks of something else so he can
Surge and have more intensity he's
addicted to intensity
um
and that's his superpower which is a lot
greater than the superpower of being a
good Observer but I think also
uh to build on that it's not just
addiction
to like Risk and drama there's always a
big mission
above it so I would say uh it's an
empathy towards
people in the big picture
it's an empathy towards Humanity
Humanity more than the empathy towards
the three or four humans who might be
sitting in the conference room with you
and that's a big deal and you see that
in a lot of people you see it uh Bill
Gates or Larry Summers uh
Elon Musk
they always have
empathy for these great goals of
humanity
and at times they can be clueless about
the emotions of the people in front of
them or callous sometimes
musk as you said
is driven by Mission more than any
person I've ever seen
and it's not only Mission it's like
Cosmic missions meaning he's got three
really big missions
one
is to make humans a space-faring
civilization make us multi-planetary or
get us to Mars number two is to bring us
into the era of sustainable energy to
bring us into the era of electric
vehicles and solar roofs and um battery
packs and third is to make sure that
artificial intelligence is safe and is
aligned with human values and every now
and then I'd talk to them and we'd be
talking about startling satellites or
whatever or he would be pushing the
people in front of him in SpaceX and
saying if you do this we'll never get to
Mars in our lifetime and then he would
give the lecture how important it was
for human consciousness to get to Mars
in our lifetime and I'm thinking okay
this is the pep talk of somebody trying
to inspire a team or maybe it's a type
of of uh pontification you do on a
podcast but on like the 20th time I
watched them I realized okay I believe
it he actually is driven by this his
frustrated and angry that because of
this particular minor engineering
decision
the big mission is not going to be
accomplished it's not a pep talk it's a
literal frustration
and impatience of frustration
and um
it's also
just probably the most deeply ingrained
thing in him is his mission he joked at
one point to me about how much he loved
reading comics as a kid and he said all
the people in the comic books they're
trying to save the world but they're
wearing their underpants on the outside
and they look ridiculous and then he
paused and said but they are trying to
save the world and whether it's starlink
in Ukraine or Starship going to Mars or
trying to get a global new Tesla I think
he's got this epic sense of the role
he's going to play in helping Humanity
on big things
and like the the characters in the comic
books it's sometimes ridiculous but it
also is sometimes true
when I was reading this part of the book
I was thinking of all the young people
who are struggling in this way and I
think a lot of people are in different
ways whether they grow up without a
father whether they grow up with
physical emotional mental abuse or
Demons of any kind as you talked about
and it's really painful to read but also
really damn inspiring
that if you
sort of
walk side by side with those demons if
you don't let that pain break you
or somehow Channel it if you can put it
this way that you can achieve you can do
great things in this world well that's
um an epic view of why we write
biography which is more epic than I'd
even thought of so I say thank you
because in some ways what you're trying
to do is say okay
I mean Leonardo you talk about being a
misfit he's born illegitimate in the
village of Vinci and he's gay and he's
left-handed and he's distracted and his
father won't legitimize him
and uh
then he wanders off to the town of
Florence and he becomes the greatest
artist and engineer of the early
Renaissance of that part of the
Renaissance
I hope this book inspires Jennifer
Dowden of the gene editing Pioneer who
discovers helps discover crispr Gene
Eddington which my book The Code Breaker
she grew up feeling like a misfit you
know in Hawaii in a Polynesian Village
being the only white person
and also trying to live up to a father
who pushed her so if people can read the
books
and I should have said about Jennifer
dad and my point was that she was told
by her school guidance counselor no
girls don't do science you know science
not for girls you're not going to do
math or science and so it pushes her to
say all right I'm gonna do math and
science let's just interrupt real quick
but uh Jennifer Donna you've written an
amazing book about her uh Nobel Prize
winner crisper developers just
incredible one of the great scientists
in the 21st century right and I'm
talking about when Jennifer doudner was
young and she felt really really out of
place like you and me and a lot of
people when they feel in that way they
read books they go into they curl up
with the book so her father drops a book
on her bed called the double helix the
book by James Watson on the discovery of
the structure of DNA by him and Rosalind
Franklin and Francis Crick and
she realizes oh my God girls can become
scientists my school guidance counselor
is wrong
so I think
books
like she read this book and even if it's
a comic book like Elon Musk read
books can sometimes inspire you
and every one of my books is about
people who are totally Innovative who
weren't just smart because none of us
are going to be able to match Einstein
and mental processing power but we can
be as curious as he was and creative and
think out of the box the way he did or
Steve Jobs put it think different and so
I hope with my books I'm saying
uh this isn't a how-to guide but this is
somebody you can walk alongside you can
see
Einstein growing up Jewish in Germany
you can see Jennifer doudner growing up
or as an outsider or a Leonardo da Vinci
or Elon Musk you know in really violent
South Africa with a psychologically
difficult father and getting off the
train when he goes to any apartheid
concert with his brother and there's a a
man with a knife sticking out of his
head and they step into the pool of
blood and it's sticky on their souls
this causes
you know scars that last the rest of
your life
and the question is not how do you avoid
getting scarred it's you know how do you
deal with it Einstein too
uh one of my and it's hard to pick my
favorite of your
um biographies but Einstein I mean you
really paint a picture of another
I don't want to call him a misfit but a
person who doesn't necessarily have a
standard trajectory through life of of
success
so absolutely and it's that's extremely
inspiring
I don't know exactly what question to
ask there's a million well I'll talk
about the misfit for a second because
you know we talked about Leonardo being
that way you know Einstein's Jewish in
Germany at the time when it starts
getting difficult uh he's slow in
learning how to talk and he's a visual
thinker so he's always daydreaming and
imagining things
the first time he applies to the Zurich
Polytech because he runs away from the
German
education system because it's too much
learning by route
he gets rejected by the Zurich Polytech
now it's the second best school in
Zurich and they're rejecting Einstein I
tried to find but couldn't the name of
the admissions counselor at the apology
yeah like you rejected Einstein uh and
then he doesn't finish in the top half
of his class and once he does and he
goes to graduate school they don't
accept his dissertation so he can't get
a job he's not teaching it he even tries
about 14 different high schools
gymnasium uh to get a job and they won't
take him so he's a third class examiner
in the Swiss patent office in 1905.
third class because they've rejected his
doctoral dissertation
and so he can't be second class of first
class because he doesn't have a doctoral
degree and yet he's sitting there in the
stool in the patent office in 1905 and
writes three papers that totally
transform science
and if you're thinking about being
misunderstood or unappreciated in 1906
he's still a third class Patrick in 1907
he still is it takes until 1909 before
people realized that this notion of the
theory of relativity might be correct
and it might upend all of Newtonian
physics how is it possible
for three of the greatest papers in the
history of science to be written in one
year by this one person is there some
insights wisdoms you draw plus he had a
day job as a patent examiner and there's
really three papers but there's also an
addendum because once you figure out
quantum theory and then you figure out
relativity and you're understanding
Maxwell's equations and the speed of
light
uh he does a little addendum that's the
most famous equation in all of physics
which is E equals m c squared so it's a
pretty good year
it partly starts because he's a visual
thinker and I think it was helpful that
he was at the patent office rather than
being the acolyte of uh some professor
at the Academy where he was supposed to
follow the rules and so at the patent
office that doing devices to synchronize
clocks because the Swiss have just gone
on Standard time zones and swiss people
as you know tend to be rather you know
Swiss they care if it strikes the hour
in Basel it should do the same and burn
at the exact answer so you have to send
a light signal between two distant
clocks and he's visualizing what's it
look like to ride alongside a light beam
he says well if you catch up with it if
you go almost as fast it'll look
stationary but Maxwell's equations don't
allow for that and he said he's making
my palm sweat that I was so worried and
so he finally figures out because he's
looking these devices to synchronize
clocks that if you're traveling really
really fast would look synchronous to
you or synchronous eyes to you is
different than for somebody traveling
really fast in the other direction and
he makes a mental leap that time
that the speed of light's always
constant but time is relative depending
on your state of motion so it was that
type of out of the box thinking those
leaps that made 1905 his miracle year
likewise with Musk
I mean after General Motors and Ford
everybody gives up on electric vehicles
to just say I know how we're going to
have a path to change the entire
trajectory of the world into the era of
electric vehicles and then when it comes
back from Russia where he tried to buy a
little rocket ship so he could send a
experimental Greenhouse to Mars and they
were poking fun of him and actually sped
on them at one point in a drunken lunch
this is very fortuitous because on the
ride back home on the plane on the you
know Delta Airlines flight he's like
doing the calculations of how much
materials how much metal how much fuel
how much would it really cost and so
he's visualizing things that
other people would would just say is
impossible it's what Steve Jobs's
friends called the reality Distortion
field and it drove people crazy it drove
them mad but it also drove them to do
things they didn't think they would be
able to do you said visual thinking I
wonder if you've seen parallels of the
different styles and kinds of thinking
that uh
that
operate the minds of these people so if
uh is there parallels you see between
Elon Steve Jobs
Einstein Da Vinci specifically in how
they think I think they were all visual
thinkers perhaps coming from slight
handicaps as children meaning you know
Leonardo was left-handed a little bit
dyslexic I think
um and certainly Einstein had a career
he would repeat things he was slow in
learning to talk
um so I think visualizing helps a lot
and with Musk
I say it all the time when I'm walking
the factory lines with them or in
product development where he'll look at
say the heat shield under the Raptor
engine of a Starship booster
and it'll say why does it have to be
this way couldn't we trim it this way or
make it or even get rid of this part of
it and he can visualize the material
science isn't small anecdotes in my book
but at one point he's on the Tesla line
and they're trying to get 5 000 cars a
week in 2018. it's a life or death
situation and he's looking at the
machines that are bolting something to
the chassis and he insists that Drew
Bagley uh not Drew but Lars moravi one
of his great lieutenants come
and they have to summon him and he says
why are there six bolts here
and Lars and others explain well for the
crash tests or anything else the
pressure would be in this way so you
have to and they were blah blah blah
blah blah and he said no if you
visualize it you'll see if there's a
crash it would the force would go this
way and that way and it could be done
with four bolts
now that sounds risky and they go test
and they engineer but it turns out to be
right I know that seems minor but I
could give you 500 of those where in any
given day he's
visualizing the physics of an
engineering or manufacturing problem
that sounds pretty mundane
but for me if you say what makes him
special there's a mission-driven thing I
give you a lot of reasons
but one of the reasons is he cares not
just about the design of the product but
visualizing the manufacturing and of the
product the machine that makes the
machine and that's what we failed to do
in America for the past 40 years we
Outsource so much manufacturing I don't
think you can be a good innovator if you
don't know how to make this stuff you're
designing and that's why musk puts his
designer's desk right next to the
assembly lines and the factories so that
they have to visualize what they drew as
it becomes the physical object so
understanding everything from the
physics all the way up to the to the
software it's like end to end well
having an end-to-end control is
important certainly with Steve Jobs I'm
looking my iPhone here it's a big deal
that Hardware only works with Apple
software and for a while the iTunes
Store and only what worked you know so
he has an end to end that makes it like
a Zen Garden in Kyoto very carefully
curated but a thing of beauty
for musk when he first was at Tesla and
before he was the CEO when he was just
the executive chairman and basically the
finance person person funding it
they were Outsourcing everything they
were making the batteries in Japan and
the battery pack would be at some
barbecue shop in Thailand and that sent
to the Lotus Factory in England to be
put into a Lotus Elise chassis and then
that was a nightmare you did not have
end-to-end control of the manufacturing
process so he goes to the Other Extreme
he gets a factory in Fremont from Toyota
and he wants to do everything in his the
software in-house the painting in-house
you know the the the
uh battery he makes his own batteries
and I think that end-to-end control is
part of his personality I mean there's a
but it also what allows Tesla uh to be
Innovative yeah I got to see
and understand in detail one
example of that which is the development
of the brain of the car in autopilot
going from mobileye to in-house building
the autopilot system to uh basically
getting rid of all sensors that are not
uh rich in data to make it AI friendly
sort of saying that we can do it all
with vision and like you said removing
some of the bolts so sometimes it's
small things but sometimes it's really
big things like getting rid of radar
well Vision only getting rid of radar is
huge and everybody's against everybody
and that's still fighting it a bit
they're still trying to do a Next
Generation some form of radar but it
gets back to the first principles you're
talking about visualizing well he starts
with the first principles and the first
principles are physics uh involve things
like well humans drive with only visual
input they don't have radar they don't
have lidar they don't have sonar and so
there is no reason in the laws of
physics that make it so that Vision only
won't be successful in creating
self-driving now that becomes an Article
of Faith to him and he gets a lot of
pushback
but now and he's by the way not been
that successful in meeting his deadlines
of getting self-driving he's way too
optimistic
but it was that first principles of get
rid of unnecessary things now you would
think lidar why not use it like why not
use a crutch it's like yeah we can do
things Vision only but when I look at
the stars at night I'll use a telescope
too
well you could use lidar but you can't
do millions of cars that way at scale at
a certain point you have to make it not
only a good product but a product that
goes to scale and you can't make it
based on maps like Google Maps because
it'll never be able to you know then
drive from New Orleans to Slidell where
I want to go when it's too hot in New
Orleans uh take for example full self
Drive
he has been obsessed with what he calls
the robo taxi we're going to build the
Next Generation car without a steering
wheel
without pedals because it's going to be
full self-drive you just summon it you
won't need to drive it
well over and over again all these
people I've told you about you know Lars
maravi and Drew backlino and others
they're saying okay fine that sounds
really good but
you know it ain't happened yet we need
to build a 25 000 Mass Market Global car
that's just normal with a steering wheel
and yeah he finally turned around a few
months ago and said let's do it and then
he starts focusing on how's the assembly
line going to work how are we going to
do it and make it the same platform for
robo taxi so you can have the same
assembly on likewise for full self Drive
they were doing it by coding hundreds of
thousands of lines of code that would
say things like if you see a red light
stop if there's a blinking light if the
two yellow lines do this there's a bike
lane do this if there's a crosswalk do
that well that's really hard to do now
he's doing it through artificial
intelligence and machine learning only
fsd12 will be based on the billion or so
frames from Tesla each week of Tesla
drivers and saying what happened when a
human was in this situation what did the
human do and let's only pick the best
humans the five star drivers or the Uber
drivers as Elon says and so that's him
changing his mind and going to first
principles but saying all right I'm even
going to change full self-driving so
there's not rules based it becomes AI
based just like chat GPT doesn't try to
answer your question who are the five
best popes or something by study chapter
by having
ingested billions of of uh pieces of
writing that people have done this will
be AI but real world done by ingesting
video sometimes it feels like he and
others they're building things in this
world successfully are basically uh
confidently exploring a dark room
with a very confident ambitious Vision
with that room actually looks like
like they're just walking straight into
the darkness there's no painful toys or
Legos on the ground I'm just going to
walk I know exactly how far the wall is
and then very quickly willing to adjust
as they run into they step on the Lego
and or their their body uh is filled
with a lot of pain what I mean by that
is there's this kind of evolution that
seems to happen where you discover
really good ideas along the way that
allow you to Pivot like to me
since you know since a few years ago
when you could see with Andre carpathy
the software 2.0 evolution of autopilot
it became obvious to me that this is not
about the car
this is about Optimus the robot
this this is like if we look back 100
years from now
the car will be remembered as a cool car
nice Transportation but the the
autopilot won't be the thing that
controls the car it would be the thing
that allows embodied AI systems to
understand the world so broadly and so
that kind of approach and it's and you
kind of stumble into it well Tesla be a
a car company
will it be an AI company will it be a
robotics company will it be a home
robotics company will be an energy
company and you kind of slowly discover
this as you confidently uh
like push forward with a vision so it's
interesting to watch that kind of
evolution as long as it's backed by this
confidence there are a couple of things
that are required for that one is being
adventurous one doesn't enter a dark
room without a flashlight and a map
unless you're a risk taker unless you're
adventurous the second is to have
iterative uh brain Cycles where you can
process information
and do a feedback loop and make it work
the third and this is what we failed to
do a lot in the United States and
perhaps around the world is when you
take risks you have to realize you're
going to blow things up
you know first three rockets that the
Falcon rocket that must does they blow
up even Starship three and a half
minutes but then it blows up the first
time
so I think Boeing and NASA and others
have become
unwilling to enter your dark room
without knowing exactly where the exit
is and the lighted path to the exit
and the people who created America
whenever they came over you know whether
the Mayflower is refugees from the Nazis
they took a lot of rest to get here and
now I think we have more referees than
we have Risk Takers more
lawyers and regulators and others saying
you can't do that that's too risky then
people willing to innovate and you need
both
I think you're also right on 50 100
years from now
what musk will be most remembered for
besides space travel
is real world AI
not just Optimus the robot but Optimus
robot and the self-driving car
uh they're they're pretty much the same
they're using
uh you know GPU clusters or Dojo chips
or whatever it may be to process real
world data we all got and you did on
your podcast quite excited about large
language model you know generative uh
predictive text AI That's fine
especially if you want to chit chat with
your chat bot
but the Holy Grail is artificial general
intelligence and the tough part of that
is real world AI
and that's where Optimus the robot or
full self Drive
or I think far ahead of anybody else
well I like how you said Chit Chat uh I
I would say for for one of the greatest
writers ever it's funny that you spoke
about language and the Mastery of
languages as merely chit chat you know
people have fallen in love over some
words people have gone to Wars over some
Wars I think Wars have a lot of power
It's actually an interesting question
where the wisdom of the world the wisdom
of humanity is in words or is it in
visual in visual is it in the physical I
don't really it's in mathematics it
might maybe it all boils down to math
and in the end this kind of discussion
about uh real world AI versus language
is all the same maybe I've um
gotten a chance to hang out quite a bit
in the metaverse with Mr Mark Zuckerberg
recently and boy
is the realism in there or the new like
the the thing that's coming up in the
future is incredible I got uh scanned
uh in uh Pittsburgh for 10 hours into
the metaverse and there's like a
a virtual version of me and I got to
hang out with that virtual version do
you like yourself well I I never like
myself
but it was easier to like
that other guy that was interesting
because I like you
he didn't seem to care much it's
actually lack of the empathy
but that was you know it made me start
to question even more than before like
well how important is this physical
reality because I I got to see you know
my myself and other people in that
metaverse like the details of the face
the like all the all the things that you
think maybe if you look yourself in the
mirror are imperfections all this kind
of stuff
when I was looking at myself and then
others all those things were beautiful
and it was like
it was real and it was intense and it it
uh it was scary because you're like well
are you allowed to murder people in the
metaverse because like are you allowed
to because what are you allowed to do
because you can replicate a lot of those
things and it's you start to question
what are the fundamental things that
make life worth living here as we know
as humans have you talked to Elon about
his views of we're living in a
simulation maybe and how you would
figure out if that's true yes there's a
constant light-hearted but also a
serious sense
that this is all a bit of a game one of
my theories on Elon a minor theory is
that he read Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy once too often
yeah and as you know there's a scene in
there that says uh that there's a theory
about the universe that if anybody ever
discovers the secrets and meanings of
the universe it will be replaced by an
even more complex universe and then the
next line Douglas Adams writes is and
there's another theory that this has
already happened so I'm gonna try to get
my head around that but I know that Elon
Musk tries to well there there's a humor
to that there's an enormous humor to
Hitchhiker's Guide I really think that
helped musk out of the darkest of his
periods to have sort of the sense of fun
of figuring out what life is all about I
wonder if this is a smaller side we
could say just uh I haven't gotten to
know Elon very well because the the
silliness
the willingness to engage in the
absurdity of it all
and have fun
what is that what is that uh is that
just a quirk of Personality or is that a
fundamental aspect of a human who's
running six plus companies well it's a
relief valve just like video games and
politopia and Elden ring or release
valves for him
um and he does have an explosive sense
of humor as you know and the weird thing
is when he makes the abrupt transition
from dark demon mode and you're in the
conference room and he has really become
upset about something and not only their
dog Vibes but there's dark words
emanating and he's saying your
resignation will be accepted if you die
you know Etc
and then something pops and he pulls out
his phone and pulls up a Bonnie Python's
get you know like the school of silly
walks or whichever John Cleese and he
starts laughing again and things break
so it's
it's almost as if he has different modes
the emulation of human mode the
engineering mode the dark and Demon mode
and certainly there is the silly and
getting mode
yeah you've actually opened the Elon
book with the quotes from Elon and from
Steve Jobs so elon's quote is to anyone
of offended I just want to say this is
an SNL I just want to say I reinvented
electric cars and I'm sending people to
Mars on a rocket ship did you also think
I was going to be a chill normal dude
and then the quote from Steve Jobs of
course is the people who are crazy
enough to think they can change the
world are the ones who do so um
what do you think is the role of the old
uh Madness and genius what do you think
they're all crazy in this well first of
all let's both stipulate that musk is
crazy at times I mean and
then let's figure out and I try to do it
through storytelling not through
highfalutin preaching
uh where that craziness works you know
give me a story tell me another go tell
me where he's crazy
and
you know the almost final example uh AI
but him shooting off Starship for the
first time
uh and between an aborted countdown and
the shoot-off he goes to Miami to an ad
sales conference and meets Linda
yaccarino for the first time make sure
the CEO I mean there's a very
impulsiveness to him then he flies back
they launch Starship
and
you realize that there's a drive and
there are demons and there's also
craziness
and
you sometimes want to pull those out you
want to take away his phone so he
doesn't tweet at 3am you want to say
quit being so crazy
but then you realize there's a wonderful
line of Shakespeare and measure for
measure at the very end he says even the
best are molded out of faults
and so you take the faults of musk for
example which includes a craziness that
can be endearing but also craziness
that's just like effing crazy
uh as well as
this drive and Demon mode
I don't know that you can take that
strand out of the fabric and the fabric
remains whole
I wonder
sometimes it saddens me that we live in
a society that doesn't celebrate even
the darker aspects of crazy in
acknowledging that it all as comes in
one package it's the man in the arena
versus the critic and the Man in the
rain versus the regulator and to make it
more prosaic
um
well let me ask about not just the crazy
but the cruelty so in um
you've written when reporting as Steve
Jobs was told you that the big question
to ask was did he have to be so mean so
rough and cruel so drama addicted uh
what is this answer for Steve Jobs did
he have to be so cruel for for jobs I
asked was at the end of my reporting
because that's what he asked said at the
beginning we're doing the launch of I
think
the iPad 2 it may have been Steve is
emaciated because you know he's been
sick and so I said it was what's the
answer to your question and he said well
if I had been running Apple
I would have been nicer to everybody
everybody got stock options and we've
been like a family and then I I don't
know if you know Wise he's like a teddy
bear he paused he smiled and he said but
if I'd been running Apple
I don't think we would have done the
Macintosh or the iPhone so yeah you have
to
sometimes be rough and job said the same
thing that musk said to me which is he
said people like you love wearing velvet
gloves no I don't know that I've worn
velvet cloths often but you like people
to like you you like to sweet talk
things you sugarcoat things he says I'm
just a working class kid
and I don't have that luxury if
something sucks I got to tell people it
sucks or I got a team of B players well
musk is that way as well and it gets
back to what I said earlier which is
yeah
I probably would wear velvet gloves if I
could find them at my haberdasher uh and
I do try to sugarcoat things but when I
was running CNN it needed to be reshaped
it needed to be broken it needed to have
certain things blown up and I didn't do
it you know so
bad on me but it made me realize okay
I'll just write about the people who can
do it well that thing of saying I think
probably both of them but Elon certainly
saying things like that is the stupidest
thing I've ever heard
by the way I've heard Jeff Bezos say
that I've heard Bill Gates say that I've
heard Steve Jobs say it I've heard Steve
Jobs saying about a smoothie they were
making it a whole food or something I
mean people they use the word stupid
really often and you know who else used
it Errol musk he kept making Elon stand
in front of him and saying that's the
stupidest thing you're the stupidest
person you'll never amount to anything
um
I don't know you know as John McNeil the
president of Tesla said
do you have to be that way probably not
there are a lot of successful people who
are much kinder
but um
it's
sometimes necessary
to be much more brutal and honest
brutally honest I would say than people
like
or when Boss Of The Year trophies
well as you said this kind of idea did
also send a signal this idea of Steve
Jobs of eight players it did send a
signal to everybody
it was a kind of encouragement to the
people that are all in right and that
happened to Twitter when we went to
Twitter headquarters the day before the
Takeover he was having Andrew and um
James as two young cousins and other
people from the autopilot team going
over lines of code and musk himself sat
there with a laptop on the second floor
of the building looking at the lines of
code that had been written by Twitter
engineers and they decided they were
going to fire 85 percent of them because
they had to be all in and this notion of
psychological safety and mental days off
and
working remotely he said either and then
it came up uh actually one of his um
I think it was one of the cousins or
maybe Ross Nordeen came up with the idea
of let's not be so rough and just fire
all these people let's ask them do you
really want to be all in because this is
going to be hardcore it's going to be
intense you get to choose but by
midnight tonight we want you to check
the box I'm hardcore all in I'll be
there in person I'll work you know as
much or that's not for me I've got a
family I got work balance
and you got different type of people
that way and different stages of their
life I was a little bit more hardcore
and all in when I was in my 20s than
when I was you know in my 50s and you
write about this it's a really nice idea
actually that there's two camps and you
find out I don't I wonder how true this
is it it rings true you can just ask
people which Camp are you in are you the
kind of person that Prides themselves
and enjoy staying up to 2 A.M
programming or whatever or do you see
the value of quote-unquote you know
about life work life balance all this
kind of stuff and it's interesting I
mean you like you could people probably
divide themselves in different stages in
life and you can just ask them and it
makes sense for certain companies in
certain stages of their development to
be like uh we always have teams it
doesn't even have to be whole company
and you're right it goes back to what I
was saying about rule the first secret
is sort of know thyself obviously comes
from Plato and uh everything comes from
Plato and Socrates but
um
and decide on this stage of my life am I
do I want to be a hackathon all in all
night and change the world or do I want
to bring wisdom and stability but also
have balance I think it's good to have
different companies with different
styles the problem was Twitter was at
almost one extreme with yoga studios and
mental health days off and uh enshrining
psychological safety as one of the
mantras that people should never feel
psychologically threatened and he a
member of the bitter laugh he Unleashed
when he kept hearing that word he said
no I like the words hardcore I like
intensity I like a intense sense of
urgency as our operating principle well
yeah they're people that way as well and
so know who you are and know what type
of Team you want to build versus
psychological safety and too many birds
everywhere oh yeah a lot of times musk
did things I go what the hell yeah and
among them was changing the name Twitter
and getting rid of the birds hey man
there's a lot invested in that brand
but when I watched him he thought okay
these sweet little chirpy birds tweeting
away in the name Twitter it's
not hardcore it's not intense and so for
better and for worse I think he's taking
Acts
into the hardcore realm with people who
post hardcore things with people with
hardcore views
it's not
a
a polite playpen
for
the blue checked
anointed Elite
and I thought okay this is going to be
bad the whole thing's gonna fall apart
well it has had problems but the
hardcore intensity of it is also meant
that there's new things happening there
so it's very Elon Musk
to not like this sweetness of birds
chirping and tweeting and saying I want
something more hardcore
as you've written in uh referring to the
the previous Twitter CEO Elon said
Twitter needs a a fire breathing dragon
I think this is a good opportunity to
um maybe go through some of the
memorable moments of the Twitter Saga as
you've written about extensively in your
book like from the early days of
considering the acquisition to uh how it
went through to the details of uh like
you mentioned the engineering teams well
at the beginning of 2022
he was riding high but as we say he's a
drama addict he doesn't like the ghost
and you know Tesla told a million
vehicles I think 33 boosters you know uh
uh Falcon nines have been shot up and
landed safely in the past few months
um
and he was the richest person on Earth
and times person of the year
and yet he said you know I'm still want
to put all my chips back on the table I
want to keep taking rest I don't want to
savor things he had sold all of his
houses so he started secretly buying
shares of Twitter
January February March becomes public at
a certain point he has to declare it
and we were here in Austin
that gigafactory on the mezzanine and he
was trying to figure out well where do I
go from here
and at that time it was early April they
were going to offer him a board seat and
he was going to do a standstill
agreement and stop at 10 or something
now remember you know we were standing
around it was Luke nozick whom you know
well Ken howery some of his friends on
that mezzanine here and all afternoon
and then late into the evening at dinner
is like should we do this
and I didn't say anything I'm just the
Observer but everybody else is saying
excuse me why do you want to own Twitter
and Griffin his son joined it down in
May for some reason was in town and like
everybody says no we don't use Twitter
why would you do that and may said well
I use Twitter and it's almost like okay
the demographics are people my age or
May's aide
um and so it looked like he wasn't going
to pursue it they offered him a board
seat
and
um
then he went off to Hawaii
to Larry Ellison's house which he
sometimes uses he was meeting a friend
Angela Bassett an actress and instead of
enjoying three days of vacation
he just became supercharged and started
firing off text messages including the
fire breathing dragon on me I think you
know he used that phrase a few times
that parag wasn't the person who was
going to take Twitter to a new level and
then by the time he gets to Vancouver
where Grimes meets him they stay up all
night playing Eldon ring he was doing a
TED talk and then uh at 5 30 he finished
his playing the Eldon ring and sends out
that I've made an offer
uh even when he comes back people are
trying to intervene and say excuse me
why are you doing it
um and so it was a rocky period between
late April and October when the deal
closes and people ask me all the time
well did he want to get out of the deal
I said which Elon are you talking about
at what time of day because there'll be
times in the morning when he'd say oh
the Delaware Court's going to force me
to do it it's horrible talk to his
lawyers you can win this case get me out
of it
he met here in Austin with three or four
investment bankers Blair Ephron it's
interview Bob Steele at perella Weinberg
and they offered him options do you want
to get out do you want to stay in do you
want to reduce the price
and I think his he was Mercurial there
were times he would text me or say to me
this is going to be great it's going to
be the accelerant
to do x.com the way we thought about 20
years ago
uh and so it's not until they finally
tell them at the beginning of October
right when Optimus the robot is being
unveiled in California actually
um that the lawyer is saying you're not
going to probably win this case but
better go through with the deal
and by then he's not only made his peace
with it he's kind of happy with it at
times
eventually the deal is going to close on
a I think a uh Friday morning I have it
in the book and we're there on Thursday
and he's wandering around looking at the
stay woke t-shirts and
psychological safety lingo they're all
using and he and his lawyers and bankers
hatched a plan to do a flash close
and the reason for that was if they
closed the deal after the markets had
closed for the day
and he could send a letter to parag and
two others firing them quote for cause
and this will be something the courts
will have to figure out
uh then he could save 200 million or so
and it was both the money but for him a
matter I won't say a principle but of
hey they misled me about the numbers I
got forced into doing it so I'm gonna
I'm gonna try this Jiu Jitsu maneuver
and be able to get some money out of
them then when he takes over it's kind
of a wild scene
um
him trying to decide in three different
rounds how to get the staff down to 15
percent of what it was him deciding on
Christmas Eve after he'd been in a
meeting where they told him we can't get
rid of that Sacramento server Farm
because it's native of redundancy he
says no it's not and he's flying here to
Austin and young James says why don't we
just do it ourselves he turns the plane
around they land in Sacramento and he
pulls him out himself so it was a manic
period we should also say that
underneath of that there was a
a running desire to or consideration to
perhaps start a new uh companies to
build the social media company from
scratch well Kimball wanted to do that
and Kimball here at a wonderful
restaurant in Austin of launches like
hey why are you buying Twitter let's
start one from scratch and do it on the
blockchain yeah now it took them a while
and you can argue it one way or the
other
to come to the conclusion that the
blockchain was not fast enough in
responsive time enough to be able to
handle a billion tweets you know in a
day or so
he gets mad when they keep trying to get
him to talk to Sam bankman freed who's
trying to say I'll invest but we have to
do it on the blockchain Kimball is still
in favor of starting a new one and doing
it on uh blockchain based
in retrospect
I think starting a new Media Company
would have been better he wouldn't have
had the baggage or the Legacy that he's
breaking now in Breaking the way Twitter
had been but it's hard to have millions
and millions hundreds of millions of
true
true users not just trolls and start
from scratch as others have found as
Mastodon and blue sky and threads and
not any threads even had a base so it
would have been hard yeah and uh to do
that in the way he did requires uh
another part that you write about with
the Three Musketeers and the whole
engineering the firing and the bringing
in the engineers to try to sort of go
hardcore so there's a lot of interesting
sort of questions to ask there but the
high level can you just comment about
that
part of the Saga which is
bringing in the engineers and seeing
like what can we do here right he
brought in the engineers and figured
that the amount of people doing Tesla
full self-driving autopilot and all the
software there was about one tenth of
what was doing software for Twitter and
he said this can't be the case and he
fired 85 percent in three different
rounds the first was
just firing people because they looked
at the coding and they had a team of
people from Tesla's autopilot team
grading the codes of ever of all that
was written in the past year or so then
he fired people you know who didn't seem
to be totally all in or loyal and then
another round of layoffs so
uh
at each step of the way almost everybody
said that's enough it's going to destroy
things yeah uh from Alex Sparrow his
lawyer to Jared Burchell he's like whoa
whoa whoa you know and even Andrew and
James the young cousins who are tasked
with making a list and figuring out
who's good or bad saying we've done
enough we're going to be in real trouble
and they were partly right I mean there
was degradation of the service sum but
not as much as half the services I use
half the time you know and
I wake up each morning and
hit the app and okay still there what do
you think was that too much I think that
he has an algorithm that we mentioned
earlier that begins with question every
requirement but it's up to is delete
delete delete
every part there and then a corollary to
that is if you don't end up adding back
20 of what you deleted then you didn't
delete enough in the first round because
you were too tempted well so you asked
me did he overdo it he probably overdid
it by 20 percent which is his formula
and they're probably trying to hire
people now to keep things going
but it sends a strong signal
to people that are hired back or the
people that are still there the the API
and what Steve Jobs and many other great
leaders felt and certainly Bezos and
certainly
in the early days of Microsoft Bill
Gates it was Hardcore only a players so
how much of Elon success would you say
elon's uh Steve Jobs's success is the
hiring and managing of great teams when
I asked Steve Jobs at one point what was
the best product you ever created
I thought he'd say maybe the Macintosh
or
maybe the iPhone
he said no those products are hard the
best thing I ever created was the team
that made those products and that's the
hard part is creating a team and he did
you know from Johnny Ive to Tim Cook and
at EQ and Phil Schiller
Elon has done a good job bringing in
people Gwen Shotwell obviously
Linda yaccarino she's you know can
navigate through the current crises
uh certainly
Stellar people at SpaceX like Moncton
Cosa and then at Tesla like Drew
backlino and Lars maravi and Tom Zhu and
many others
um he's not as much of a team
collaborator essay Benjamin Franklin who
by the way that's the best team ever
created which is the founders and you
had to have really smart people like
Jefferson and Madison and really
passionate people like John Adams and
his cousin Samuel and really a guy of
higher rectitude like Washington but you
also needed a Ben Franklin who could
bring everybody together and Forge A
team out of them and make them
compromise with each other
musk is a magnet for awesome Talent
magnet interesting but there's the
there's like the priorities of hiring of
um
based on Excellence trustworthiness and
drive these are things you described
throughout the book I mean there there's
a pretty
uh concrete and rigorous
the set of ideas based on which the
hiring is done oh yeah and he has a very
good Spidey uh intuitive sense just
looking at people
who could I mean not looking at them but
studying them who could be good one of
his uh
uh
ways of operating
is what he calls a skip level meeting
and let's take a very specific thing
like the Raptor engine which is powering
the um Starship and it wasn't going well
it looked like a spaghetti Bush and it
was going to be hard to manufacture and
he got rid of the people
who were in charge of that team and now
remember that he spent a couple of
months doing what he called skip level
which means instead of meeting with his
direct reports on the Raptor team he
would meet with the people one level
below them and so he would skip a level
and meet with them and he said this is
and I just ask them what they're doing
and I drill them with questions and he
said this is how I figure out who's
going to emerge he said it was
particularly difficult I was sitting in
those meetings because people were
wearing masks it was doing the height of
covid uh and he said it made it a little
bit harder for him because he has to get
the input but I watched as a young kid
dreadlocks named Jacob McKenzie he's in
the book
is sitting there and he's a bit like you
engineering mindset speaks in a bit of a
monotone musk would ask a question and
he would give an answer and the answer
would be very straightforward and he
didn't you know get rattled he was like
this
it must said one day called him up at
three well let's say three a.m but after
midnight said you still around yeah Jake
said yeah I'm still at work and he said
okay I'm Gonna Make You in charge of the
team building Raptor
and that was like a big surprise but
Jacob McKenzie has now gotten a version
of raptor and when they're building him
at least one a week and they're pretty
awesome and
um that's where his talent must Talent
for
finding the right person and promoting
them that's where it is and promoting it
in a way where it's like here's the ball
here catch yeah yeah and you run with it
I have I've interacted with quite a few
uh folks from even just the model X the
the all throughout where people you know
on paper don't seem like they would be
able to run the thing and they run it
extremely successfully and he does it
wrong sometimes he's had a horrible
track record with the solo roof division
wonderful guy named Brian Dow I really
liked him uh and when they were doing
the battery Factory surge in Nevada
uh musk got rid of two or three people
and there's Brian Dow can do can do can
do stays up all night and he gets
promoted and runs it and so finally goes
uh musk goes through two or three people
running the solo roof division finally
calls up Brian down I was sitting in
Moss house in Boca Chica that little
tiny two-bedroom he has and he offers
Brian Dow the job of running solar roof
and you know buying their okay can do
can do and two or three times musk
insisted that they put install a solar
roof in one of those houses in Boca
Chica this is this tiny village at the
south end of Texas
and late at night I mean I'd have to
climb up to the top of the roof on these
ladders and stand on this peaked roof as
musk is there saying why do we need four
screws to put in this single leg and and
Brian was just sweating and doing
everything but then after a couple of
months it wasn't going well and boom
uh musk just fired him
so I always try to learn what is it that
makes those who stay thrive
what's the lesson there what do you
think well I think it's self-knowledge
like an Andy Krebs or others they say uh
I am hardcore I really want to get a
rocket to Mars and that's more important
than anything else
uh one of the people I think it's I
think it's Tim Zaman I hope uh when he
hears this I'm getting him the right
person who you know took time it was
working for Tesla autopilot and it was
just so intense he took some time off
and and then went to another company he
said I was burned out at Tesla but then
I was bored at the next place so I
called I think it was Ashok it I said
can I come back he said sure he said
I've learned about myself I'd rather be
burned out than born that's a good line
um well can you just uh Linger on one of
the three that seemed interesting to you
in in terms of Excellence
trustworthiness and drive which one do
you think is is the most important and
the hardest to get at the
trustworthiness is an interesting one
like are you ride or die kind of thing
yeah I think that especially when it
came to taking over Twitter he thought
half the people there were disloyal and
he was wrong about two-thirds were
disloyal not just that
and it was how do we weed out those and
he did something and made um the firing
squad I call it or the Musketeers I
think is my nickname for them which is
you know the young cousins and two or
three other people he made them look at
the slack messages these people had post
everybody at Twitter and posted and they
went through hundreds of slack messages
so if anybody
posted on the internal Slack
you know that jerk Elon Musk is going to
take over and I'm afraid that he's a
maniac or something
they would be on the list because they
want all in loyal uh they did not look
at private slack messages and I guess
people who are posting on a corporate
slack board should be aware that your
company can look at them but that's more
than I would have done or most people
would have done
and so that was to figure out who's
deeply committed and loyal I think that
was mainly the case at Twitter he
doesn't sit around at SpaceX saying
who's loyal to me
at
um other places
it's excellent but that's pretty well a
given everybody is like a mark jencosa
just whip smart it's all you hardcore
and all in especially if you have to
move to this spit of a town in the South
Tip of Texas called Boca Chica
you know you got to be all in yeah and
that's the drive the the last piece
so you in terms of collaborating one of
the great teams of all time Ben Franklin
I like that
um I thought it was the Beatles but Bank
Franklin is pretty good no no no no no
no I'm sorry yeah I'm sorry to offend
you so read the Constitution and read
Abby Road look at Abbey Road they're
both good but they're in a different
League yeah different League okay so uh
one of the many things that comes to
mind with Ben Franklin is incredible
time management
um
is there something you could say about
Ben Franklin and about
um Steve Jobs I think interesting with
Elon is that he as you write uh run six
companies
depends how you count startling because
its own thing I don't know
um what can you say about these people
in terms of time management well musk is
in a league of his own and the way he
does it first of all
yeah Steve Jobs had to run Pixar and
Apple for a while but musk every couple
of hours is switching his mindset from
how to implant the neural link chip and
what will the robot that implants it in
the brain look like and how fast can we
make it move
and then the heat shield on the Raptor
or switching to human imitation machine
learning full self drive on the night
that the Twitter board
uh agreed to the deal
this is huge around the world I'm sure
you'll remember like musk buys Twitter
it wouldn't win the deal closed it was
when the Twitter accepted is offer and I
thought okay
but then he went to Boca Chica to South
Texas
and spent time
fixating on if I remember correctly a
valve in the Raptor engine that had a
methane leak issue
and what were the possible ways to fix
it
and all the engineers in that room
I assume are thinking about this guy
just bought Twitter should we say
something and he's like and then he goes
with Kimball to a roadside joint
uh in Brownsville and just sits in the
front and listens to music with nobody
noticing really him being there
one of the things that one of his
strengths and sort of weaknesses in a
way
is in a given day
he'll Focus serially sequentially on
many different things he will worry
about
uh uploading video onto x.com or the
payment system and then immediately
switch over to some issue with the FAA
giving a permit for Starship
or with how to deal with starlink and
the CIA
and when he's focused on any of these
things
you cannot distract him it's not like
he's also thinking about I'm dealing
with starlink but I've got to also worry
about the Tesla decision on the new 25
000 car
now he'll in between these sessions
process information then let off steam
and for better or worse he lets off
steam by
either playing a friend in politopia or
fire off some tweets which is often not
a healthy thing but it's a release for
him
and he doesn't I once said he was a
great multitasker and that was a mistake
people corrected me he's a Serial Tasker
which means focuses intensely on a task
for an hour
almost has a what do they call it at
restaurants where they give you a
palette cleanser yeah he does some
palette cleanser with polytopia yeah and
then focuses on the next task I mean is
there some wisdom about time management
that you can draw from that there are
some things that these people do and you
say okay I can be that way I can be more
Curious I can question every Rule and
regulation
I I just don't think anybody
to try to emulate musk time management
style because it takes a certain set of
teams you know how to deal with
everything else other than the thing
he's focusing on and a certain mind that
can shift just like his moods can shift
uh you and I go through Transitions and
also if I'm thinking about what I'm
going to say on this podcast I'm also
thinking about the email my daughter
just sent about a house that she's
looking you know and I'm
I'm multitasking he doesn't actually do
that he single tasks sequentially with a
focus that's hardcore I don't know I
think there's wisdom to draw from that
to like
first of all he makes me Ben Franklin
makes me feel that way that there's a
lot of hours in the day there's a lot of
minutes in the day like
there's no excuse not to get a lot done
and that requires just an extreme Focus
an extreme focus in like an urgency I
think the fierce
urgency
that
drives him is important
and it's sometimes gend up
like I say the fierce urgency of getting
to Mars and on a Friday night at the
launch pad in Boca Chica at 10 pm there
are only a few people working because
it's a Friday night they're not supposed
to launch for another eight months
and he orders The Surge he says I want
200 people here by tomorrow working on
this pad we have to have a fierce sense
of urgency or we will never get to Mars
that sense of urgency you know
is also a vibrancy
that's like really taking on life fully
I mean that to me this the lesson is
like
even the mundane can be full of this
just richness and like you just have to
really uh take it in intensely so like
the switching
enables that kind of intensity because
most of us can't hold that intense than
any one tasks for a prolonged period of
time maybe that's also a lesson
right and I guess it goes back to also
know who you are meaning there are
people who
can focus intensely and there are people
who can see patterns across many things
look Leonardo da Vinci
he was not all that focused he was
easily distracted it's why he has more
unfinished paintings and finished
paintings in his Canon yeah
um but his ability to
see patterns across nature and to in
some ways
process procrastinate be distracted
that helped him some
but musk is in not that way and there
every few months as a new surge you
don't know where it'll be but you'll be
on solar roofs and all of a sudden we'll
have a surge and there has to be you
know 100 solar roofs built or this has
to be done by tomorrow or make a
Starship dome by Dawn and Surge and do
it
um and there are people who are built
that way it is inspiring
but also let's appreciate you know that
there are people who can be really good
uh
but uh also can savor
the success Savor the moment Savor the
quiet sometimes
must big failing is he can't save her
the moment or success and that's the
flip side of Hardcore intensity
in uh innovators another book of yours
that I love you write about individuals
and about groups
so one of the questions the book
addresses is is it individuals or is it
groups that turn the tides of History
when Henry Kissinger was on the shuttle
missions for the Middle East peace this
is the first book I ever wrote
he said when I was a professor at
Harvard
I thought that history was determined by
great forces and groups of people
but when I see it up close I see what a
difference an individual can make he's
talking about Sadat and Golda May are
probably talking about himself too or at
least in his mind and um we biographers
have this dirty secret that we know we
distort history a bit by making the
narrative too driven by an individual
but sometimes it is driven by an
individual mask is a case like that and
sometimes as I did with the innovators
there's teams and people build on each
other and Gordon Moore and Bob Noyes
than getting Andy Grove and doing the
microchip which then comes out and
Wozniak and jobs find it at some
electronics store and they decide to
build the apple
and so sometimes they're
flows of forces and groups of people
I guess I air a little bit on the side
of looking at what is Steve Jobs and
Elon Musk and Albert Einstein can do
and also try to figure out if they
hadn't been around with the forces of
history and the groups of people have
done it without them that's a good
historical question as uh it's you know
somebody loves history and you think
about special relativity one of the 1905
papers
even after he writes it it's four years
before people truly get what he's saying
which is it's not just how you observe
time is relative it's time itself is
relative and on the general theory which
he does a decade later I'm not sure we
would gotten that yet
uh what about moving us into the era of
an iPhone in which it's so beautiful
that you can't live without a thousand
songs in your pocket email and uh the
internet in your pocket and the phone
uh there are a lot of brain dead people
are from Panasonic to Motorola who
didn't get that and it may have been a
while
I certainly think it's true of the era
of electric vehicles Jim and Ford all
the great people there they crushed the
boat and I mean that literally they
ended up smashing them because they
decided to discontinue it likewise
nobody was sending up Rockets our space
shuttle was about to be grounded
12 years ago
and so musk does things
and they'll be people who say and read
the book if they read the book they'll
see the full story but they say it
wasn't musk who did Tesla it was Martin
Eberhard or Mark tarponing no no no you
know there were people who had helped
create you know the shells of companies
and other things and they were all
deserved to be called co-founders but
the guy who actually gets us to a
million electric vehicles a year
is Elon musking without him
I don't think we look if
anybody five years is from now buys a
car that's gasoline powered well think
that's quaint you know that's odd I mean
suddenly we've changed we're not going
to do it
ninety percent of that is Elon Musk
we're all mortal
when and how do you think Elon will
retire from the insanely productive
schedule he's on now
I would think that he would hate to
retire I think that he can't live
without the pressure the drama
they all in feeling
um
it's never
been anything that seemed to have
crossed his mind he's never said maybe I
love Larry Ellison's house on the beach
in Hawaii maybe I should spend time in
doing instead he says things like I
learned early on that vacations will
kill you
he gets malaria when he goes on one big
I mean he goes on vacation at one point
and they oust him from PayPal and then
he goes to Africa one boy he gets
malaria he says I've learned vacations
kill you lesson learned well it's
interesting because the projects are
100 plus year projects many of these one
of the weird things
is watching him think
incredibly long term
one of the meetings every week
early on when I was watching him was
Mars colonizer and we did to a two-hour
meeting about what would the governance
structure be on Mars what would people
wear how would the robots work and
would there be democracy or should there
be
a different form of
governance
I'm sitting there saying what are they
doing what are they talking about
they're trying to build rocket ships and
everything else they are worrying about
the governance structure of Mars and
likewise
whenever he's in an intense Moment Like
There's a Rocket's about to be launched
he'll start asking people it's not in
the way future like the new
leaked engine or something if we're
going to build that do we have enough
materials ready to order or
I don't know he'll just ask questions
like when he's building Robo taxi the
global car the 25 000 inexpensive Global
car that's not a total passion he was
talked into doing that his passion is
Robo taxis but his passion is how are we
going to make this Factory to do a
million cars a year so even the robo
taxi is a longer range Vision I mean
he's been touting it since 2016. but you
know we're not I don't know Robo taxis I
mean there's waymo may be doing a little
experiments but there's not cars being
manufactured without steering wheels
that are going to take over the highways
yet so he's always looking way into the
future as my point I just hope that uh
there's a lot of Da Vinci's and Steve
Jobs's and Einsteins and Elon musk's
that carry the the flame forward that's
one of the reasons you write books about
these people is so that if you're a
young woman in a school where you're not
being told to do science and you read
the code breaker about Jennifer doudna
you say okay I can be that and when you
say oh maybe I'll be a regulator or you
say oh no maybe I'll be the person who
pushes
the boundaries who pushes the lines who
pushes as Steve Jobs said the human race
well let me ask you about
your mind
your Genius
your process I'll give you two out of
three all right uh take me through your
process of writing a biography I mean
the the full of it and not just writing
a biography but understanding
deeply
which your books have done for the human
story and like the bigger ideas
underline the human story so you've
written biographies both of individuals
which are hardly individuals it's a
really big complex picture and
biographies of
ideas
that involve individuals well step one
for me is trying to figure out how the
mind works
um
what causes Einstein to make that leap
free-line musk to say stainless steel
while he's looking at a carbon fiber Rob
rocket or how do you make the mental
leap because I write about smart people
smart people are a dime a dozen they
don't usually amount to much you have to
be creative imaginative to think
different as Jobs would say
and so what makes people creative what
makes them take imaginative leaps that's
the key question you gotta ask you also
ask the questions like you've asked
earlier which is what demons are
jangling in their head and how do they
harness them into drives so you look at
all that and you try to observe really
carefully uh the person
of one of the more mundane things I do
is
a lot of writers
try to give you a lot of their opinions
and preach or whatever
uh as I said this Mentor said two people
types come out preacher's storytellers
be a Storyteller
um
I try
whenever I'm trying to convey a thought
there's six magic words that I almost
should have written on a card
penned above my desk which is let me
tell you a story
so if somebody says how does Elon Musk
figure out good talent
as you did
I think well let me tell you the story
I'll tell you the story of Jake McKenzie
or this is not something I invented I
mean this is where the good Lord does it
in the Bible I mean has the best
openings lead sentence ever you know in
the beginning comma and then it's
stories and secondly to pick up on that
lead sentence in the beginning make it
chronological everybody
in the 40th year of their life has grown
from the 39th year and the 38th year and
so you want to show how people evolve
and grow
I had the greatest of all non-fiction
narrative editors Alice Mayhew at Simon
Schuster who among other things created
All the President's Men with wood and
burns but she had a note she'd put in
the margins of my books that was a tigta
and it meant all things in good time
keep it chronological if it's good
enough of the Bible it's good enough for
you interesting to me like that's a
small note but to you it's it's
extremely important because it's the
framework for how you structure things
but also how you understand things which
is if you keep it a chronological
narrative
then you're showing how a person has
grown from one experience you've talked
about to the next one and that moral
growth creative growth risk-taking
growth
wisdom that's the Essences of creativity
but you can't do it uh you know there's
a Tom buildings woman you know which is
a you know book of you know that carries
a narrative and tells how people learn
something
I'm a big believer in narrative if
you're an academic
you sometimes not today but in like 20
years ago 30 years ago
there were two things you thought were
bad one was
uh having a great person theory of
history in which you decide to do
biography I had a great Professor when I
was in college her name was Doris Kearns
she later married dick Goodwin and she
when she was going for tenure at the
University
photobiography of Lyndon Johnson and The
American Dream and they denied her
tenure because it was beneath the
Dignity of the academy to write history
through one person
uh that's great it opened up the field
of biography to us non-academics uh
starting with David McCullough
Bob Carroll but maybe John Meacham and
myself are in a new generation and
certainly there's a generation coming
after us
but the second thing besides telling it
through people which
is
the academy tended to disdain what they
called imposing a narrative in which you
made it storytelling because that meant
you were leaving things out and making
it into a narrative well
that's how we form our views of the
world
well let me ask you this question in
terms of gathering and understanding
how much of it is one observing
and how much of it is interviews
yeah
um and obviously depends on the subject
I mean whether Ben Franklin it's all
based on archives and every of course we
have 40 volumes of letters he wrote that
was the good old days when every day
you'd write 20 letters
the must book is based much more on
observation than almost any of my books
because he opened up in a way that was
breathtaking to me
you know even when he'd be sitting
playing
polytopia or
seething at other people you know he had
me just sitting there watching
I mean I spent a lot of time with
Jennifer Dowden in her side I went to
her lab and edited a human gene and you
know with a pipette and a test tube but
I would say I spent
30 hours with her I can't count you know
100 hours or more just observing Musk
and I'm not
sure
that any biographer perhaps since
Boswell took on Dr Johnson has ever had
quite as much
up close meaning five feet away at all
times
access
and because of that I'll go back to what
I said a moment ago I try to get out of
the way of the story it's not about me
is that I try to just say okay
here's what happened here's this story
here's what happened the night he came
in to Twitter for the first time and let
you form your own judgment
what about the interviews
you've had
a lot of conversations uh you give
acknowledgment to the people you've
you've done interviews with
uh well one I have to ask
as an inspiring interviewer myself
uh how people love to talk people just
love you know that and I've had 140
maybe 150 people they're all listening
back
one of the little things that people
won't notice but I'll say it now is all
of them are on the record getting them
to talk is easy they all want to talk
about musk but then at a certain point
say I don't put Anonymous quotes in my
book
I cite things
I say if you're tough enough
and you've gone through this and a lot
of times it takes two or three calls
back somebody will tell me so I say oh
no no I don't enjoy
but I think it's important to know where
everything came from and with mosque
it's you know I had that from the very
beginning because I was a Time Magazine
reporter I'd worked reporter for the
Times Picayune on New Orleans I first
day on the job I had to go cover a
murder and uh I phoned in the story from
a pay phone and my editor you know the
city editor said well did you talk to
the family I went no Billy I mean the
family you know the daughter just got he
said go knock on the door I knocked on
the door an hour later they were still
talking they were bringing me out her
yearbooks lesson one I learned people
want to talk if you're willing to just
listen
and whether it be Henry Kissinger you
just push the button and say kiss and
Jordan people tell you the stories all
the way through Elon Musk
everybody talked everybody in his family
everybody he fired everybody I mean
I think it's important to listen to
people and the other thing I learned as
a reporter back when I was covering
politics in New Hampshire in the early
campaigns
I learned from two or three great
reporters a guy named David Broder and
Tim Rosser the late NBC guy they do what
was called door knocking you just walk
in the neighborhood knock on a door and
ask people about the election but they
said here's the secret
don't ask any leading questions don't
have any premise just say hey I'm trying
to figure out this election what's going
on
what do you think and then stay silent
but musk a third secret you know this
well
he'll go silent at times
sometimes a minute two minutes four
minutes don't try to fill the silences
if you're a listener
you gotta learn
okay he's not shining thing for four
minutes I can Outlast him it's tough
It's as humans it's very tough
respecting the silence is really really
difficult
I've speaking of demons
when there's silence all the demons show
up in my head oh dear the fear I think
is if I if I don't say anything it's
boring and if I say something it's going
to be stupid
that that the basic engine that just
keeps running not on the podcast well on
the podcast but also in human
interaction and so I think there's that
nervous energy when interacting with
people you can never go wrong
by staying silent if if there's nothing
you have to say not something I've
mastered but I do when I'm a reporter
try to master that which is
don't
don't ask complex questions
interject and when somebody hasn't fully
answered the question don't say well let
me I haven't fully just stay silent and
then they'll keep talking just give them
a chance to keep talking even if they've
kind of finished you're still sometimes
they haven't given you enough instead of
following up I'll just
nod and key Point you're making it sound
simple is there a secret to getting
people to open up more I'm somewhat
lucky because you know I started off
working for a Daily newspaper
and people back then
they want to talk to the newspaper
report but you also have a way about you
like I feel like you have uh like a
cowboy in a saloon like you just kind of
want to talk like there's a draw I don't
know
I don't know what it is maybe this I
don't know if it's developer you're born
with it but there's a it feels like I
want to tell you a story of some sort
good tell me a story
a couple things
I did learn
to be more quiet I'm sure I know when I
was younger or even
I'll see videos of me at you know it
news things where I'm always trying to
interject a question and so you learn
to be quieter sometimes I haven't
mastered it I haven't learned it enough
you learn to be naturally curious many
reporters today when they ask a question
or either trying to play gotcha or
trying to get a news scoop or trying to
you know gig something that can make a
lead
and
if you actually are curious and you
really want to know the answer to a
question
then people can tell that you asked it
because you want the answer not because
you're playing a game with them
I'm sure some of them off the Record
some of them on the records you had
maybe you know
what just some incredible conversations
I was going to say some of the greatest
conversations ever but who knows some of
the best conversations ever are probably
somewhere in South America between two
drunk people that we never get to hear
so I don't I don't know but uh is there
a device you can give
from what you've learned to somebody
like me and how to have good
conversation
especially when it's recorded
well do we actually curious I mean every
question you've asked me is because I
think you actually want to know the
answer and you've done your homework
to be open and not to have an agenda
I mean we all
suffer from there being too many agendas
in the world today
yeah so they're just genuine curiosity
but
um there's something when you talk about
just one-on-one interaction
whether it's Elon or Steve Jobs or
there's something
beautiful about that person's mind and
it feels like
it's possible to reveal that
to discover that together
uh efficiently
and that's kind of the goal of a
conversation well I mean look you're
amongst the top
podcasters and interviewers you know in
the world today
you have an earnestness to you
um Ben Franklin is the person who taught
me
I mean by reading him the most about on
conversation he wrote a wonderful essay
on that it includes on silence uh
But it includes
trying to ask sincere questions rather
than
get a point across I mean
it's somewhat Socratic
but
whenever he wondered I wanted to like
start a fireman's core in Philadelphia
he would go to his group that he called
the leather apron Club
and they would pose a question why don't
we have it
what would it take what would be good
and then the second part is to make sure
that you listen and if somebody has even
just the germ of an idea
give them credit for it like as Joe said
you know the real problem is this
and
I do think
that
if I'm in situations and I just mean
even a dinner or something I'm with
somebody
I'm usually curious and I'll the
conversation will proceed you know with
with questions and I guess it's also
because I'm pretty interested in what
anybody's doing whoever I happen to be
with
and tell you that's a Talent you you
have which is you're pretty genuine in
your interests
the people
like Benjamin Franklin like the I'll say
Charlie Rose even though he's in
disfavor who are interested in a huge
number of subjects and I think that
helps as well to be interested in
basketball and Opera and physics and
metaphysics
uh that was a Ben Franklin that was a
Leonardo trick which is
they wanted to know everything you could
possibly know about every subject
knowable
but there's a different aspect of this
which is um that I would love to hear
how you've solved it or if you faced it
that you're certainly disarming
uh see I'm like uh pepperoni with
compliments here trying to get you
that's a very disarming method yeah I've
recently talked to Benjamin Netanyahu
we'll we'll talk again we unfortunately
because of scheduling and complexities
only had one hour which is very
difficult very difficult with the
charismatic politician Minister I
understand this but he's also a
charismatic talker which is very
difficult to break through in one hour
but there people have
built up walls whether it's because of
demons or because of their politicians
and so they have agendas and narratives
and so on and so to break through those
um I wonder if there's some advice some
wisdom you've learned on how to uh sort
of wear down through water or whatever
whatever method the the walls that we've
built up as individuals I mean you call
it disarming which I don't know that I
am but disarming basically means you're
taking down their Shields also
and you know when people have a shield
and you try to give them Comfort I had
zero of that problem with Elon Musk I
mean it was like disarming to me which
is I kept waiting to say okay he's not
gonna always they've got a shell or he
won't do that but he was
um almost
crazily open
and
did not seem to
uh want to be spinning or hiding or
faking things
um
and I've been lucky
daltona was that way Steve Jobs was that
way
but you have to put in time too in other
words um
you can't say okay there's a one hour
interview and I'm gonna
break down every wall it's like on your
fifth visit yes well actually it was one
of the things in my situation you learn
fifth visit is very nice but sometimes
you don't get a fifth visit sometimes
it's just the first date and um I think
what it boils down to and we said
disarming but there's something about
this person
that you trust I think a lot of it just
boils down to trust in some deep human
way and I think uh with with uh with
many other people I've spoken with
sometimes the trust happens like after
the interview which is really sad
because it's like oh man I've never been
in your situation where I have a show
I usually have
I'm not a first date person yeah yeah
well you know but then I'm lucky I mean
I'm in I say lucky but I'm in print you
know print is a
couple thousand Euro medium but they're
those of us who love it well the nature
of the podcast medium is that I'm a one
one night stand kind of girl
uh let me ask you about objectivity
you've followed Elon and it follows like
you're I mean I don't know if you would
say your friend you have to be careful
with words like that but you're there's
an intimacy
um and how do you remain
objective
do you want to remain objective while
telling a deeply human story yeah I mean
I want to be honest which I think is
akin to being objective
uh I try to keep in mind
who's who am I writing for
I'm not writing for Elon Musk as I say I
haven't sent them the book I don't know
if he I don't think he's read it yet
um
I've got one person I'm writing for the
open-minded reader
and
if I can put in a story and say well
that will
piss off the subject or that will really
make the subject happy that's irrelevant
or I try to make that a minor
consideration it will the reader
and have a better understanding because
I've put this story in the book
I'm a bit of a romantic
so to me even your Einstein book yeah
had lessons on on romance and
relationships oh dear
so how important are romantic
relationships to the success of Great
Men great women great minds
well sometimes people who affect the
course of humanity have better
relationships with Humanity than they do
with the humans sitting around them
Einstein
had two interesting relationships with
wives That's what you know maleva his
first wife was a sounding board and help
with the mathematics of the special
relativity paper in particular
um but he didn't treat it well I mean he
uh made her like sign a bladder that she
wasn't interrupt him she wouldn't you
know and finally when she wanted a
divorce he couldn't afford it because he
was still a patent Clerk
and so uh he offered her a deal which is
I think totally amazing he said one of
these days one of those papers from 1905
is going to win the Nobel Prize
if we get a divorce
uh you know I'll give you the money
um that was a lot of money back then
like a million dollars now or something
and she's smart she's a scientist she
consults with a few other scientists and
after a week or so she takes the bat
it's not until what 1919 that he wins
his Nobel Prize
uh and she gets all the money she buys
three apartment buildings in Zurich uh
with his second wife Elsa it was more a
partnership of convenience it was not a
romantic love but he knew and that
sometimes what people need in life is
just a partner I mean somebody who's
going to handle the stuff you're not
going to handle
so I guess if you look at my books
they're not great inspiring guides to
personal relationships
let me ask you about actually the
process of writing itself
when you've observed when you've
listened when you've collected all the
information what's uh maybe even just
the silly mundane question of
uh what do you eat for breakfast before
you start writing when do you write
first of all breakfast is not my
favorite meal and those people who tell
you that you have to start with a hearty
breakfast I
uh look Askins yes uh and morning is not
my favorite day part it's all right at
night
and
because I love narrative it's easy to
structure a book which is I can make a
outline that if I printed it out or
notes would be
a hundred pages but everything's in
order
in other words if we sort if there's a
burning man and he's coming back from
Grimes and then there's a solar roof
thing and then there's something I put
it all in order day by day
as an outline and that disciplines me
when I'm starting to write
to follow the Mantra from Alice Mayhew
my first editor which is all things in
good time don't get ahead of the story
don't have to flash back
um and then after you get it so that
it's all chronologically nothing then
you have to do some clustering you know
you have to say okay we're going to
do the decision to do Starship or to
build a factory in Texas or to whatever
and then you sometimes have the
organizational problem of yeah and that
gets us all the way up to here
do I keep that in this that chapter or
do I wait until later when it's better
chronologically but those are easy well
what about the actual
process of telling the story well that's
the Mantra I mentioned earlier which is
whenever I get
pause or I don't know how to say
something I just say let me tell you a
story yeah and then I find
the actual anecdote the story
the tale that encompasses what I'm
trying to convey and then I don't say
what I'm trying to convey I don't have a
transition sentence that says you know
Elon sometimes changed his mind so often
he couldn't remember whether he had
changed his mind you know you know you
don't need transition sentences you just
say all right here's the point I need to
make next and so you start with a
sentence that says
you know one day in January in the
factory in Texas comma
well one of the things I'd love to ask
you is uh
for advice for for young people to me
first advice would be to read
biographies in the sense because
they help you understand of all the
different ways you can live a life well
lived
but from having written biography having
studied so many great men and women what
advice could you give to people of how
to live this
this life well I keep going back to the
classics and Plato and Aristotle and
Socrates
uh and I guess it's Plato's maximum but
he may be quoting Socrates that the
unexamined life is not worth living
and it gets back to the know thyself or
nothing which is
you don't have to figure out what is the
big meaning of it all well but you have
to figure out why you're doing what
you're doing
and
that requires something that I did not
have enough of when I was young
which is self-awareness
and examining every motive everything I
do
where does the examination Lead You is
it uh to uh
to a shift in
in life trajectory I mean it's not for
me sort of all right I've now decided
having been a journalist I'll run a
think tank or I'll run a network or I'll
write a bio
it is actually something that's more
useful on an hourly basis
like why am I about to say that to
somebody or why am I going to
do this particular Act
what's my true motive here
and also in the broader sense to learn
as I did after a couple years at CNN
I I my examination of my life is that
I'm not great at running complex
organizations
I'm not great as a manager given the
choice I'd Rather somebody else have to
manage me than me have to manage people
ah but it took me a while to figure that
out and I was probably too ambitious
when I was young and at Time Magazine
that was when I was green and
oh well uh that was when I was in my
salad days in Green in judgment
and it was like chasing
the next level at time Incorporated
whatever it might be
and then one day I caught the brass ring
and I became an editor and then the top
editor and after a while I realized
uh that wasn't really totally what I'm
suited to be especially when I got put
in charge of CNN
I mean all young people are almost by
definition in their salad days and green
and judgment
but
you learn what's motivating you and then
you learn to ask
but is that really what I want should I
be careful of what I'm wishing for
one of the big examinations you can do
is the fact that you and everybody dies
one day
how much you are there I think so think
about death are you afraid of it no and
I don't think about it a lot but I do
think about Steve Jobs is let me tell
you a story you know which is the
wonderful Steve Jobs story of um I think
after he was diagnosed but before it was
public and he gave both a Stanford talk
but other things in which he said
the fact that we are going to die
gives you focus and gives you meaning if
you're gonna live and Elon Musk has said
that to me which is a lot of the tech
Bros out in the Silicon Valley they're
looking for ways to live forever forever
I can think much as of nothing worse uh
we read the myth of Sisyphus and we know
how bad it is to be condemned to
eternal life
so
there was an ancient Greece the person
who walked behind the king and said
momento Mori remember you're gonna die
and it kept
people
from
losing it a bit do you think about
Legacy the lucky thing about being a
biographer
is that you kind of know what your
legacy is there's going to be a shelf
it'll be of interesting people and you
will have inspired a 17 year old biology
student somewhere to be
gen you know the next great biochemist
or somebody to start a company like Elon
Musk
um
and
what I think more about I won't say
giving back that's such a trite thing I
moved back to New Orleans
for a reason first of all the hurricane
hit and after Katrina I was asked to be
by share the recovery Authority and I
realized everything I've got going for
me it all comes from this beautiful
Gem of a troubled City
the wonderful high school I went to the
wonderful
streets where I learned to ride a bike
you know
and it's got challenges I'm never going
to solve challenges
at the Grand Global level but I can go
back home and say part of my legacy is
going to be I tried to pay it back to my
hometown even by teaching at tooling
which I don't do as a favor I mean I
enjoy the hell out of it but it's like
all right I'm part of a community and I
think we lose that in America because
people who are lonely or lonely because
they're not part of a community but I've
got all my high school kids their
friends they're all still in New Orleans
I've got my family but I also have
Tulane institutions in New Orleans that
have been there forever
and if I can get involved in helping the
school system in New Orleans of helping
the Youth Empowerment programs of
helping the Innovation Center at Tulane
I was even on the City Planning
Commission which worries about zoning
ordinances for short-term rentals
you know go figure but it was like no
immerse myself in my community because
my community
was just so awesomely good at allowing
me to become who I became
and has
trouble year by year Hurricane by
hurricane making sure that each new
generation can be creative and it's a
city of creativity from Jazz to the food
to the architecture so when I think of I
want to say Legacy but what am I going
to do to pay it forward which is a lower
level way of saying Legacy I pay it
forward by going back to the place where
I began and trying to know it for the
first time
mm-hmm
that was a uh rip-off of a T.S Eliot
line I don't want you to think I thought
of that one
uh always cite your sources I appreciate
it T.S Elliott if you ever need to
figure it out
the four questions that part at the end
which is we shall not see some
exploration in the end of all of our
exploring will be to return to the place
where we started and know it for the
first time
through the unknown but half-remembered
gate it's just beautiful and that's been
an inspiration
of
what do you do
in
I guess if it's a Shakespeare play you'd
call it Act five
well you go back to the place where you
came and
see if you don't sit there worrying
about Legacy but you'll sit there saying
how do I make sure that somebody else
can have
a magical trajectory starting in New
Orleans
well to me you're one of the greatest
storytellers of all time I've been a
huge fan definitely not true but it's so
sweet of me you see you can be rudely
interrupting is this is uh the from
um I think
probably Ben Franklin
so far I don't know how many years 15
years Einstein all the way through today
has just been a huge fan of yours and
you're one of the people that I thought
surely would not lower themselves
to appear and have a conversation with
me uh and it's just a giant gift to me
hey I flew into Austin for this because
I am a big fan
and especially a big fan because you
take people seriously
and you care thank you a thousand times
thank you for respecting me and for
inspiring just millions of people with
your stories again an incredible
storytelling incredible human and thank
you for talking today thank you Alex
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Walter Isaacson to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with one of my favorite
quotes from Carl Young
people will do anything
no matter how absurd in order to avoid
facing their own Souls
one does not become enlightened by
imagining figures of light but by making
the darkness conscious
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time